[Music]
hey everybody time for the matinee show
and again just like last week I guess
because it was Thanksgiving week we
didn't really have time to go to the
theater because we were busy doing
holiday stuff and all this the other
thing so we stayed in and watched three
movies I think we're all on Netflix
no that was one of them was on shudder
yeah two of them were on chatter one was
on right yeah Netflix I think or maybe
they were all in shudder I don't know
how I remember but anyway I know the
second - were on chatter but yeah
actually the first one might be - now
that I'm thinking about it so these are
all shuttered movies this week all right
so the first one that we saw I actually
saw this one a couple weeks ago and
didn't get around to reviewing it but
then I watched it again today so it
would be ready for the review this is
haunt now this just premiered at a the
popcorn frights Film Festival in August
of this year and subsequently had a
rather limited theatrical release and
then went to shudder and various other
VOD platforms now there have been like a
lot I didn't it didn't really occur to
me until I was kind of reading about it
thinking about it and I was like there
been a really lot of horror movies in
the last few years that have been set in
haunts you know what I mean it was like
a you know a haunted house that people
go to like on Halloween they have a bit
scary I'm sure like that I mean there
was the whole Hell House LLC franchise
one of which we reviewed that was
Hellfest I've seen so many I'm gonna get
him all confused yeah there was one
called American Fright Fest there was
another one called bloodfest there's a
lot of fest movies so this one is the
same kind of premise it's basically a
slasher and it's set inside like an
extreme haunt that said um this one was
actually like better than I was
expecting and I mean it's nothing like
fantastic it's nothing like to write
home about or anything like that it's
not there's not original premise or you
know there's nothing mind-blowing about
it or anything but it was actually like
a pretty enjoyable I enjoyed it a lot
more than I thought I would just the one
that was I get them all confused this is
the one that it had the CG at the very
that wasn't all that great the one where
it was like a sequel there's some people
coming back to life from heaven no I
from Hell okay it's not the same one no
that's it completely okay this one's me
they're all the same yeah this one was
actually I think this is written by the
same two guys that did a quiet place and
it was actually produced by Eli Roth so
that's probably you know why it got like
a little more fanfare than some of the
other ones like maybe Hellfest
um I actually liked this a bit better
than Hellfest I just think that the
character development was better the
characters were more likeable but
basically what she got is you have the
main character whose name is Harper and
she has a shitty abusive boyfriend and
she is just he's just punched her in the
face so she has like a black eye and
stuff like that and it's Halloween night
and her roommate and some of their other
friends they all of their costumes on
they're like you know come out with us
and like [ __ ] that guy and all this
other crap yeah yeah so she's like
trying to play it off cheek you know
covers the bruised up with makeup and
everything and they drag her out for
Halloween night and they're kind of out
at a club and she meets a guy that's
really nice and all this other kind of
[ __ ] so then they're trying to decide
what they should do with their night and
they decide that they're gonna go to a
haunt now one of them gets a flyer for
one of those ones that's like an extreme
one you know which they have in real
life and they want to try and find that
one but then they're kind of driving
around looking on their phones and you
know there's other ones in the area and
they're trying to decide they're
squabbling over which one they're gonna
go to and all this other stuff so
eventually there's another thing too
where the main character Harper who is
kind of you know the other character is
a kind of I don't want to say they're
like stock characters cuz all the acting
and this is like surprisingly pretty
good and like I said the characters are
all fairly likable none of them are like
please die or and it's you know what I
mean none of them are that bad so but
she's kind of the only one that gets a
significant backstory you know she's got
the abusive boyfriend she's got
apparently her dad was abusive also
which is why she's kind of repeating the
cycle so they do she has like a few
flashbacks in there and stuff and it
kind of ties in with you know her
character arc of like finding her
strength I guess you know going through
this haunted house so it's almost kind
of
can almost see it it's like kind of a
metaphorical thing it's like her casting
off her past and like you know going
back and taking back her strength and
you know conquering or fear or whatever
so she thinks that before they even get
to the haunt she thinks she sees
somebody like stalking them somebody
that's like in a devil kind of outfit
it's like a red cloak and like a weird
mask and stuff and she thinks it's her
boyfriend you know as you would but so
she thinks that they're being followed
and the creepy thing is they're driving
and driving and she she sees this truck
behind them and she makes them stop
because she's like what the [ __ ] I think
somebody's following and then there's
nobody back there but then all of a
sudden this sign that nobody saw before
just goes light comes on and it says
haunted house and they're like oh that's
the one that we got the flyer for let's
go up there and check that out so they
get in there there's a creepy clown they
take their cell phones away which you
know like I said they do that in real
life so you don't like photograph [ __ ]
inside and since this is a horror movie
you will not be surprised to learn that
they start getting picked off one by one
however just like in I think the cool
thing what makes a lot of these movies
work even though like I said it's not a
hugely original premise it's not
mind-blowing or anything but what makes
this work is that the protagonists are
in a situation where you could be
forgiven for thinking that the [ __ ] that
was happening in front of you was fake
because at one point one of their
friends like gets lost cuz they get
separated because they go off in
different directions and doing other
things and there's little rooms and
stuff and you know she kind of reappears
later and it looks like somebody kills
her but in a way that it could be fake
also you know what I mean so I think
that's kind of like a good aspect and
it's kind of what makes it a little bit
more realistic because if you were in an
extreme haunted house they make you sign
a waiver and all this other kind of [ __ ]
so if horrible [ __ ] started happening
you wouldn't immediately cop to the fact
that oh [ __ ] this is real and I have to
get out of here you know what I mean so
it's it kind of makes it a little bit
more because in a real in a slasher
movie a lot of times if they're in like
a real-life quote-unquote situation and
you're like well why don't you just get
the [ __ ] out of there it's like why you
hanging around in this place when
there's clearly
murderer but in this one it takes them
longer because they're not sure what's
fake and what's not moot horror movies
like this done in this style kind of
room kinda I put them on par with this
like the found footage type yeah movies
you know Blair Witch Project was the
first my room yeah this is not found
footage though not found footage but
there's something about that this
particular genre this peculiar tone of
horror kana I put it up there with that
found footage yeah to me they're not bad
they're not great to me they're kind of
like I put them on par kind of like the
the MCU and see like Disney movies
they're they feel kind of generic and
soulless to me they do BAE yeah and and
so this some people maybe depends on how
old you are what you grew up with I
think maybe younger people might like
these but all older people like me you
know we see them and they just don't
feel right you know what I mean yeah
here's a good example
people love the MCU to me I can watch an
MCU movie and enjoy it but as soon as
it's over forget every bit of it well
yeah I don't really I don't really
remember them and then you put that put
that up like a month later now okay now
you compare that with Joker another
superhero movie but Joker was a film
yeah movie yeah you know I'm talking
about that was the film with the cap
that was a film that's the way these
things kind of feel you know I mean
they're kind of feel a little generic of
Solus they do you don't really remember
them that much the other two that we
talked about on here more along the
lines of what what I consider to be like
a real movie well the energy that we're
going to talk about had more of like
memorable prey yeah I remembered them
and you know and and they had the feel
of a movie that had some damn soul to it
yeah yeah no but well like I said I feel
like there's absolutely nothing wrong
with this movie this is a movie where
you know it's just it's you know maybe
if it's Friday night you've had a couple
beers and it's like you kind of like I
just want to watch like a slasher movie
they don't have to think too hard about
it like super complicated switch for
this
it has like some really good like some
well-executed you're like I said the
acting is good and it's got like good
it's good pace it's good tension you
know what I mean you actually kind of
care about what happens in here you get
bummed out if they die MCO movie MCU
movie there's nothing wrong with them
yeah okay it's just that for some reason
they don't really stick with you yeah
well what I'm talking about and I feel
like that happens with it because look
it's like I love horror movies and I'll
watch them all day long and I think that
happens with pretty much every genre
there's really only a handful of movies
that you know resonate with you enough
that like you know a year later two
years later you still remember it you
know what I mean and and it's very rare
in any genre and even movies that I like
at the time you know even once cuz this
one I watched a couple of times like in
preparation for the review it's like
it's a good movie it's like it's a
perfectly enjoyable movie it's not but
like I said it was just kind of like how
fast it's like we had a great time
watching it yeah but it's like I don't
really remember all that much about it
you know even though it's it was fun
when you saw it and this is like a
similar thing it's not like a hugely
original premise like I said and
especially in the last couple years
because there been a lot of movies you
know set in a haunt environment probably
out of those I think probably Hell House
LLC the first one is probably my
favorite just because and even though I
don't usually like found footage but I
really think that was really well done
but this is actually a good one too and
I like how this ended you know it's got
like some really nice gore set pieces
some of its CGI but they did what they
did was you know it's very low-budget
but they did a lot of practical effects
and then put CGI over it so at times you
can tell it's CGI but it's not really
that bad because a lot of it is still
practically done and I kind of liked you
know the way they had the the haunt
setup it's like when you first go in and
it looks like kind of a cheap Jack like
Jaycees haunted house kind of thing and
it's like that's kind of what it would
really be like but then it just kind of
gets worse and worse like as it goes on
so this is a perfectly fine movie you
know fun to watch for Halloween or
whatever if you're like really into
horror movies it's nothing that's you
know you need to write home about or
anything like that but you know it's
perfectly fun if you like that kind of
thing and like I said it's pretty gory
surfing the slashers no tits or anything
like that but sorry to disappoint any
tip fans out there yeah well you know no
nudity but I think it kind of has to
happen in horror movies well that's what
well I mentioned it cheap [ __ ] well
they mentioned it because slashers I
mean that's kind of the two things
they're known for is like your tits and
it's like so this doesn't have any tits
but the gore is good though and like
there's actually one Gore gag in it feel
like with someone's face get peeled off
or something like that that was actually
really really well done and it like
really liked it you know what I mean
that was really good but you know check
it out it's on shudder I think I think
you can also rent it you know in various
other VOD platforms Amazon Prime YouTube
whatever so check it out if you like
slash
you
all right now the second movie we saw
this week this one kind of came out of
nowhere just turned up on shutter you
know unexpectedly so we decided to watch
it because it looked kind of crazy
this is called necro tronic I think it's
also called necromancer
yeah this is a Australian this is an
Australian once again the Australians
are bringing it I like this one I did
this it was kind of retro it was kind of
no not really retro I guess you say is
traditional in the way that the writing
and the layout and the scores vary score
was great it was traditional Hollywood
you know big classical [ __ ] score I
liked it I think they did have some up
some rock in it too just gotta watch it
but it felt kind of like a like a
Spielberg movie it didn't read it kind
of like and it had like a lot of oh ma
jizz - every horror kind of classic
there was some magis - ghostbusters in
there it had like a freight elevator
Hellraiser I had kind of a frighteners
sort of vibe going on um you know so
there was all kind of that should alien
alien yeah had just had shout outs -
everything was in it pretty much yeah
and it had a little bit of a retro look
it was kind of um you know a lot of like
neon colors and practical effects and
practical effects probably demons yeah
it also something also there was a lot
of what'd he call it Evil Dead oh yeah
Ashley the Evil Dead kind of situations
yeah this is kind of like okay so the
two biggest stars in this are Monica
Bellucci who's you know very famous
actress and also David Wenham who
actually was in some of them was in the
Lord of the Rings movies among many many
other things so this deals with David
when there's two characters who at the
beginning are that what do they work
like they're kind of like a septic tank
service or something and go up there
this truck that it needs suck the [ __ ]
out of the [ __ ] subject yeah and it's
like I laugh cos their company I can't
remove the name of the company was but
their motto was we take your crap yeah
you know there's a lot of humor in this
movie yeah you know so I like that town
very much cuz
very much kind of like an evil dead Tom
yeah with a lot of action you know is
just [ __ ] broke humor and fart jokes
and [ __ ] just whatever yeah it was it
was like lowbrow humor but I like you in
a kind of like yeah high concepts yes
sci-fi type of yeah and and the movie is
actually packed full of action humor and
effects and horror yeah ants - there's a
lot going on a lot happens something
happens every few minutes so there
aren't any really slow spots in it yeah
not really yeah I mean I I can see how
cuz I've been um watching some other
people's reviews of this like after we
watched it it seems like about half and
half some people really dug it some
people thought it was good but thought
it needed a series because there was
just like because the story was so
because there was so much going on and
it was so convoluted because basically
what what ends up happening these two
guys that work for this like you know
septic tank sucking company yeah
it's kind of like a harry potter
situation where like the one guy doesn't
know like what his powers aren't [ __ ] so
his kind of dumb buddy he's working with
him he's discovered this new mobile app
that's essentially like Pokemon go
except as ghosts and demons it's like
you can go Sun again and you can bring
them in through the dimension eventually
there's like demons are trying to demons
are have kind of ordered the
installation of kind of like 5g but it's
like a special satanic 5ji yeah like she
allows demons to come in through another
dimension so it all that that element
started to go a little bit kind of like
the matrix
yeah matrix type stuff going on it's
just it's just a fun movie you're not
supposed to take any of this [ __ ]
seriously they just packed a lot into
one movie yeah and that's the font of
the movie yeah though and I think one of
the best things about it like I said
it's a very complicated story um the
kind of pre credit sequence or this
sequence which is animated and it kind
of like describes what because Monica
Bellucci cheese character I guess she's
kind of like some kind of demon queen or
she okay
so there's people called necromancer's
with a k' and i guess since the
beginning of time they've been like
fighting these demons and stuff now
Monica Bellucci z' character used to be
a necromancer but I guess she like
defected and she like went to the dark
side and decided that she wanted to be
like demon queen so she has I don't know
how long she's been alive I guess it's
been a really long time but she has
instituted this new game that I guess
when you download it and play it and you
like capture these ghosts with your
phone
you're like capturing actual demons and
then they possess you and like all this
other kinda stuff so she's like trying
to collect Souls for you know world
domination or what have you so um so
then you have like David Wenham
character and his two daughters who are
there I thought they were just trying to
bring hell on earth maybe they were I'm
not sure very sure they're never really
try to make too much don't try to make
too much out of this movie or try to
make sense out of it really it did make
sense but you don't care when you're
watching it yes people fighting demons
and demons appear and it's something
like it's like Evil Dead yeah I didn't
keep track out and like I'm bringing
people back here maybe printer's yeah if
you know some kind of yeah you can write
nures action American Werewolf in London
there was a little bit watching Evil
Dead you're not wondering what the
Deadites are trying to do how many times
and by what technology is happening and
how that you don't you just [ __ ] your
wife to the movie you're laughing at the
movie and drinking I guess or that's
yeah it's like good like I said this one
I had not heard a single thing about
this um it just popped up on shudder
like in the new arrivals and I was like
the poster looked great and I was I saw
some of the some of the negative reviews
I just laughed at the negative reviews
too you know I mean they're trying to
make sense out of a [ __ ] movie like
this I will the movie like this
seriously I did see one guy that kind of
liked the movie but he's like I wish
they would made they would have made it
into a series because he's like this
could I mean because the scope of the
story was so large
very ambitious movie or as little of a
budget as they had right and to a large
extent I think they did a really good
job I mean they got like some really
great actors they got some great special
effects going in there you know and some
and the humor it's juvenile but it's
funny you know what I mean yeah they
were saying these Jude the humors so jus
I'm not you guys why beginning I thought
work that [ __ ] out laughed out I was in
high school we had a really good time
with yeah I was like because I all I
knew about it like I said was I thought
the poster looked cool on shutter and
like I read there's little Iggy and a
little two sentence you know description
or whatever and at first I was kind of
like well I don't know am I gonna like
that or not cuz usually I'm I'm kind of
hit or miss with like horror sci-fi
mashups almost correct it was it's like
correct for the subject it's definitely
kind of a comedy yeah more comedy it's a
horror comedy so so we're sci-fi except
there was you know the reanimate er and
from beyond and even to certain not
really so much Dagon but you know it's
it's that kind of stuff where you're not
supposed to take Bridal reanimate er you
know yeah they're supposed to take it
that seriously I don't honestly I think
this the vibe of this reminded me of the
frighteners more than anything yeah I'm
not sure why like maton poke on other
people's mileage may vary but for some
reason this gave me a very frightened or
vibrate nurse was kind of like the dark
back to the future yeah I don't really
didn't it didn't really feel like
frighteners to me parts of it did parts
of they felt like Ghostbusters though -
a little bit yeah there was there was
definitely a Ghostbusters part of it a
Hellraiser part they were there was some
pale razor Tropes
just so everybody had the bomb the box
with it looks kind of like the limit
configuration is kind of like more of a
yeah kind of thingy on it there's it
just was what it was yeah and like I
said if you like sci-fi horror comedies
and if you know if you like movies that
are kind of like it's kind of like a
throwback like it wasn't particularly -
this with the score and they almost felt
like tremors yeah I kind of got the with
the bugs but yeah yeah yeah
that started off kind of like tremors
yeah cuz it was East just these two guys
instead
thanks truck however like that around
smoking pot right yeah you know talking
to each other it's just every classic
comedy sci-fi horror comedy trope was
coming at you and they were did that
[ __ ] not a bastion on the passively yeah
I knew exactly what they were doing yeah
yeah but I mean definitely if that
sounds like something that would be up
your alley I mean I enjoyed it quite a
bit I liked it
yeah I did too I thought it was a lot of
fun and you know it was a pretty cool
movie I thought yeah yeah yeah there's a
lot of stuff going on in it but it's a
fun movie yeah do you really have to
keep track of it now probably not I mean
you probably enjoy it more if you do but
if you just want to like I said just
just like with the last movie just like
have a beer and watch the entertainment
yeah definitely so yeah it's definitely
entertaining and it's on shudder they
just added
okay and the third movie this was also
another one that just turned up on
shudder that I had not heard anything
about before watching it yeah this is
called deep murder good movie this is
another one that's gonna be like okay so
I'm gonna I don't know that either
people are really gonna like this or not
this is it's a slasher comedy it's a
comedy yeah first and foremost it does
have gore in it it does have like
slasher troupes in it but it's
definitely a comedy and actually the guy
that is directed it was from Funny or
Die you like porn you will understand
this yeah so the press the premise of
this movie that's let me see if I can
explain this so when I was like reading
the description of it on shudder I
thought that it was gonna be a slasher
movie that was set like on a porno set
that's not exactly what's going on it's
like in another dimension what's going
on is that these people it isn't a porno
movie but these people are like not
self-aware they're in a porno movie this
is so this is like a slash are taking
place in a porno movie universe yeah
where the people that are in ER are not
actors but they don't have any life
outside they don't have any
self-awareness of like life outside the
house or anything like that that's all
they know is porn yeah and they're like
bad actors bad porn and like they try to
they do porn tropes and it's just
[ __ ] fun and like they don't know so
like when somebody starts bumping off
all these people yeah like they don't
know how to deal with it because all
they know is like the is porn true
imagine and imagine imagine they're
they're like
two-dimensional porn actors yeah trying
to deal with this not so I was thinking
about this what happening in the porn
dimension and yeah it's like a different
dimension really it's kind of a concept
but yeah it's like hi it's like high
concept lowbrow yeah because I mean if
you know if you're into like kind of you
know they got all the port ropes man
yeah big black beefcake they got because
it's very good to fire 20
they got milk Birds milfs it got teen
porn star tea schoolgirl they got all
that on every you know a silver gray fox
dude every every [ __ ] porn trope
that's the characters are based on that
like there's yeah porn star characters
but like I said that made all they are
that's they know that's all they know
that's right they're not they're not
real people doing porn movies no it's
just the damn character yeah won't care
as the person like it's happening in a
parallel you that's like harder to
explain that I thought it yeah hard to
explain but you understand it when you
see cuz it it took me like when I was
first watching the movie cuz like when
the movie opens up it opens like a
standard like a terrible yeah quite porn
box horror movie yeah so I'm sitting
there watching it and then like it's
good and I'm like wait a minute they
don't know like when they stop to see
they don't know that they're in a porno
muga that's just there another in a porn
movie and it's like they don't know what
the what life is like outside or
something like that it's just it's the
craziest thing film characters under
attack they has to be a porn movie yeah
it's like the weirdest premise but if
they're bad actors they act bad through
the whole movie
yes way they are but you know wait I was
thinking because there's actually it's
like some fairly big stars in this like
Jerry O'Connell agenda can't act he was
in standby man he was in some shitty 90s
um you know one of the guys that was in
it was in he was in Greece too and he
was in like a bunch of other kind of
stuff too
you know and some of the other ones have
been on you know have like kind of big
TV roles and whatnot but it's like I was
thinking about how difficult it must be
like for an actor it's like you're an
actor and you're in a movie and you have
to act like a bad actor who is also a
person who doesn't know that they're bad
actors yeah you know what I mean I was
like wow that must have been really
difficult the porn dimension and they
all kind of like really pulled it up and
I mean that yeah I mean there's the
character like I said there's the milf
character she's like she's really gonna
fare with the Brit with the
brother-in-law like the husband who's
played by the grease 2 guy he's just
like a businessman like and he walks
around his sweat suit like yelling into
his phone like all the time and you know
there's one
girl who's I don't even have a name
she's just babysitter babysit and she
just walks around like sucking on a
lollipop laying all the time yeah and
like all day everything's like anyway -
yes she will she's a doctor not a doctor
she's dreadout a nurse out
dr. bunny van [ __ ] yeah and she's like
she well she comes in she's supposed to
be a climate scientist I guess she's not
even a doctor she's a scientist quiet
sighs she's a climate scientist and she
tells them a storm is coming but one of
the running jokes that they don't ever
like refer to it but she tells them
about like this bad storm and we're
trapped in this house even though it's
clearly very sunny outside yeah and it's
like they don't know so it's just it's
like really it's kind of like you're
playing in a laugh a minute movie yeah
like that it's like not every single
joke it's hard lands but it this is
surprisingly I mean we were dying
laughing at some points because it's
it's kind of like some of the gags are a
lot smarter than you have any right to
think that they would be you know what I
mean like and and a lot of the [ __ ] is
just they don't comment on it like I
said the whole thing about her like talk
she's a climate scientist and she's
coming like telling about the storm but
it's been it's sunny outside but no one
says anything about that everyone just
takes her word for it like oh we're
trapped in the house kind of like a
Twilight Zone episode or not Twilight's
a bit more like you know black mirror or
something yeah and then like like she
she's this all with her science you know
and everything and she's gonna try and
solve because they have a detective
character who just has this lame like
trench coat and this like ill-fitting
like hat and stuff he's acting like a
detective but he can detect but he can't
detect anything he's like a complete
idiot and so lazy he's a porn star
detective yes exactly and it's like
everybody has these kind of like where
their their outfits don't look right you
know what I mean so he's like kind of
trying to be a ruffle detective he
doesn't really look like one exactly I
think looks like cheap bathsheba's yeah
every everybody acts like what their
crappy porn equivalent would actually
like you know what I mean but that's
their real but they're really like that
yeah so bunny Van Clint is trying to
solve this murder because she thinks
that it
tuba salsa is an idiot and all she's
doing she's like she's gonna use science
to solve their burger and then she's
making like yeah like a science fair
volcano it's just like so [ __ ] funny
it's like the [ __ ] premise of this
it's just hilarious and I don't know how
they [ __ ] thought of it I'm thinking I
was just writing a script and he's
saying what if what if this horror movie
was also a porn movie he's just right in
like a bad porn movie yeah it's like a
go yeah that's what we're gonna make
it's kind of like like I said a lot of
the humor is really low brow but in a
way in a way that's like kind of genius
that's funny it was a porn it was it was
supposed to be to happen and in the porn
universe I don't even think there was
any nudity in the movie there was male
nudity there was a male full frontal
nudity right you know what I think they
might have done that on purpose although
I didn't notice it until I was watching
someone else's review of it and they
said you know there was no tits in this
yeah although there was dick it was that
like a full it wasn't like erect or
anything but there was like a big dick
like in that way they were running for
they were running from the bad guy that
the two dudes are running from the
[ __ ] killer and the killer's coming
out of in a big in a long that was
dragging on the ground
just trying to rape me run their run so
where do they run they run into the
shower to hide yeah and the steam is
going and there's just and you see them
they take their clothes off to get about
it take their clothes off to get in
because it's the shower where that's
what you do yeah I try to run from this
guy but they're in the shower and
they're somehow lost and they find each
other even baby chefs like showing it
from their point of view and it's like
they're in a huge [ __ ] huge room full
of [ __ ] Steve like a lot but then
they show the other dish showed from
another point of view just like outside
of shower it's just dudes pressed up
against name going get out and oh the
dude yeah and the killer is just like
and standing there and is looking about
him and looking at him like these guys
doing so so you know but the characters
their view of what's happening is very
different from what you're
you write because it's like all they
know how to do is porn star is what a
porn star would do so it's like when
they're like well when somebody gets
murdered like was like well what do we
do and what was the [ __ ] and then like
Shep it's like you said like this big
black guy turns up and he's like a
firefighter and he's like got like no
yes taka Kapoor started knocking on the
door on his face because the pizza guy
cuts like a dick in the body the other
characters like that was a beefcake but
it's like oh my god people get killed
with a dildo people get killed by
fisting it's just it's delightful and
it's like especially funny like I said
if you if you love that kind of cheesy
porn play from like the 80s and 90s
because I feel like that's kind of what
this is a washing but it's a it's so
moshing it in like a really smart kind
of way and it's also like I said let's
make it fun for it's making fun of it
but in a way that's like really clever
like this was much cleverer than I was
expecting it today I was just expecting
it to be a dumb slasher like said in a
porn set on a porn set no it's not yeah
it's like very high concept really like
kind of yeah it's up there with the
Contin those kind of movies you know
like Naked Gun and [ __ ] airplane and
I've seen some people comparing like a
laugh a minute tide yeah I've seen some
people compare it to Orgazmo the Trey
Parker and Matt Stone that's you know
that the South Park guys that one they
made oh yeah yeah yeah it's kind of like
that but um so if you really like this I
mean essentially like I said it's yes
it's kind of a horror slasher kind of
movie because you know that there is a
body count and there's kind of gore and
stuff in it but I would call it first
and foremost this is definitely a sex
comedy you know what I mean because it's
just pretty much the whole thing is just
porn and sexual innuendos like from it
yeah so um this was actually probably
the pleasantest surprise of our movie
watching a spirit because I thought this
was gonna be dumb as hell and I just
thought it was [ __ ] yeah I plan she's
a star to watch it as laughs yeah well
he missed the very beginning because I
think like you were in the shadows doing
something yeah and then and then you
came out you're like me
and then I had to explain and like I
said when I I thought that when I
explained it for this show like how it's
not set on a porn set it's actually like
in a porn Ian for the holidays it was
harder to explain that but yeah the
universe yeah so it's like the funny
thing it it's funny because at one point
too in the movie like the characters in
the movie starts to become like
self-aware like babysitter cuz I'm like
I said she does have a name she's just
baby sitter baby sitter at one point
it's like why am i a babysitter there
are no children in this house for me
they're babysitting so they start to
become aware that they're like
characters like in a movie and like you
know one of them finds a library and
they start learning it's just it's so so
funny and it's just there's a lot of
great like visual gags and stuff that
aren't really referred to but it's like
kind of stuff that's going on in the
background that's looking really good
but yeah it's like a really cool like a
clever script and like you know yeah we
recommend it yeah definitely watch it if
you're into horror comedies and
especially if you like like cheesy porn
and [ __ ] that's making fun of cheesy
porn because this was like just a
delightfully hilarious movie and we just
laughed our asses off
[Music]